yeah
gos
on so here we are live just doing a
pod what's your favorite thing to
podcast
about um that's a good question
um favorite thing to podcast about I
mean I can talk about anything whatever
you want
um let's talk about the bogans the Bogan
what's aogan so aogan and pronouncing
your term um is pretty much a redneck a
redneck for
Australia um we we um Bens are apparent
uh about as regular as rednecks
are they um they live out in the country
they um they say the word [__] more than
most Australians usually do and um so
you can tell the level of
bogosity by the [__] per minute 100%
you can um what's your CPM at right now
uh conss per minute um I get around at
least uh one to two conss per minute I I
say the word but I don't I don't overuse
it it it just gets excessive after um
after a few
times what' you say sorry this is it's
muster
yeah we um we say the
word at home but um yeah it's just like
something something that um Bens usually
use a bit more than regular Australians
but like how do I how do I um put it
bogans use it use it more often than not
yeah they're just more in tune with yeah
yeah it's like your nword
you we don't say that word usually we in
general we don't say that word of course
not but when you're having fun or when
you want to
relax yeah it comes out but um want to
tell a story accurately K is usually
used um way more out there than um most
words right it's like like in American
English yeah yeah so like the same way
you guys use use the word bloody bloody
the English use the word bloody yeah
yeah like the same way you guys use [__]
[__] like we say that word we say [__]
as a words word of ende demment are you
ever using it in like of adverb or a
verb like this [__] [__] no
cunted me over
cly CT cly h no not necessarily we um we
use it more as a word um as a term of
endearment like this kind this guy's
just a [__] this this guy oh you should
see the [__] on this guy yeah there we
uh sort of sorry I [__] that up you
should um you should meet this [__] this
guy's a this guy's a nice guy um um you
never usually um like for example if you
meet someone and they're like oh this
guy's a [__] this guy's a piece of [__]
you don't usually call them a [__] you
call them like just piece of [__]
but if you meet a meet a guy and he's a
he's a cool guy he's he's a cool um
person you go oh this guy's a sick [__]
um you should meet him he um you I
reckon you'll like him is it like a
nting ceremony you get cunted into the
family pretty much um you get put into
one and if you get referred to as a sick
cun this guy's a warm cut this guy's a
this guy's got extra flaps on him hey
it's exactly right guys a sick [__] this
guy is a a thing you guys say a we say a
a lot so that's the thing you share with
Canadians a yeah actually and never
thought about that like that but um we
say like a at the end of a lot of
sentences like again like this can't
sick con and um I didn't even notice you
say that yeah and it's um
it's it just rolls off the tongue and
it's not weird in our language kind [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] you let the [__]
like let the tea not be as I'm holding
in you got to like [__] [__] yeah there
we go that's a bit better [__] yeah
that's good o there o there you sick
[__] what you [__] yeah we go doing over
there that's good you bit turned a bit
Canadian at the end
but a cun a day keeps the [__] away
that's exactly right and there is [__]
in Australia where like not cool [__]
yeah when um in Australia it's a rancid
[__] yeah yeah that's a that's a great
that's a great example it's a good
adjective adjective I'm not the biggest
English proverb in Australia I don't
know if they have this in America but um
we have this thing called um English
studies which is basically the [__]
version of um English yeah um studying
English so they teach you English we
have English class in Australia yeah but
then there's English so there's English
level a and then there's English level B
which is where most people do English
and then there's English level C and
they're like the people who don't want
to get their um certificates their um
high C certificates and yeah and they
want to go on and do a trade pretty much
and a trade is considered basically like
building um doing electrician working
with your hands with your hands to a
certain extent being a blue collar
worker yeah so like being a um a plumber
as well for example so I met you at the
creek in the cave yeah you're a comedy
fan do have you ever done comedy are you
a comedian I've never done comedy um do
you know Shane Gillis I know Shane
Gillis Shane Gillis is pretty big in
Australia at the moment he's one big
everywhere we we have um there's a
certain of comedians that can perform at
this theater that we have down in
Australia especially in in Sydney yeah
the Opera House the um no the IC theater
so that's the biggest
naal I don't know what it actually
stands for that's a so Shane did that
and he met you there and he brought you
out here or something so I I watched
Shane there I met Shane here in Austin
and um
Shane [__] cuzz I saw you come in in
with Shane and his crew I was like oh
this is one of the boys I should be nice
to him yeah he um I never I met him at
the mothership for the first
time yesterday no two days ago and um
one of the nicest genuine people I've
ever met um I thought you said that was
me no you are one of the nicest genine
people I've ever met I'm one or two one
or two one of maybe three or four but uh
oh [__] it keeps growing larger by
the we um
one of my biggest um things is when I
meet people um you know what if they're
what if they're [__] what if they're
not nice people and um I met it ruins
the it ruins exactly I've met I've met
celebrities before where they're they're
not the nicest people when you Nicole
Kidman Nicole I've never actually met ni
ha Ledger he he L is dead he um yeah
well you're 18 you could have met him
when you were 12 I could have met him
when I was 12 he did a is that when he
died he died when did Dark Knight R when
did Dark Knight 2014 2014 when did The
Dark Knight Rise so when when The Dark
Knight released I was um if that was
2014 I was 12 Night Rises 2012 what
about what about just the dark knight
Dark Knight yeah the dark because that
different movie Rise is The Dark Knight
is 2008 2008 I was was um the age of 6
years old so you're a tiny little baby I
was a tiny little baby I met I might
have met him once when he was a
psychopath but well he did the second
one right no he yeah he only did the
second one when did Heath Heath Ledger
death date that'd be good to know be
like hey I can tell you when you're
going to die 2008 so you could have met
him when you were wait he did the first
one no he didn't do the first one he
didn't the second The Dark Knight yeah
that's the second one what's the first
one called bman begins Batman Begins
that's a good movie that's just when
[__] but you know not to hang out
with bats now right they give you co
this guy's hang out with bats kind of
weird all that gay [__] [__] that's sus
bro yeah where were you were you in
Wuhan where is this B cave when I
was when Co came along I remember the
day Co I first heard of Co yeah so when
it dropped yeah when it dropped when um
so in Australia we have this thing
called Shad day which is your I guess
Fourth of July Fourth of July and um is
that the day you the day on the first
[__] the day the day Kobe died is where
we first heard about the co yeah so we
um we heard about Co and it was called
the corona V virus yeah of course we
have this uh thing you guys are right by
Asia too right next to it so we have
this we also have this drink called uh
Kona you know
the Mexican beer yes the mexic beer we
drink it a lot in Australia and I was
like oh so it's a when I first heard
about I was like oh is it a drink that
um is it a disease that you catch from
drinking Corona bees yeah it was bad
branding on their part it was terrible
branding and um we we heard about it and
in my mind at the time I was kind of
like this was late January I was I was
sort of like I it's fine it's not going
to hurt anyone it's it's just another
another cold it's nothing to nothing
going to nothing to sneeze at yeah
nothing to um really exaggerate about
and um four years later did you know
yeah it was going to be the biggest
thing to exaggerate yeah and biggest
waste of time possibly in history who
knows like think so
I Australia really OV exaggerated about
the disease
we
um but what's the downside you didn't
get to we didn't get to go out we were
stuck at home if uh I mean isn't that
worth the price of uh species survival I
guess but when you when you look at the
uh when you look at like when they say
um the
disease if you get the covid vaccine you
know um you'll be immunity forever and
then you get the vaccine you're like
yeah we're immunity forever and head you
and you still get the disease you get
the Z again did the Z again and you're
kind of like what I've had it seven
times so far you've had it seven times
yeah I haven't had it nearly as much as
that and that's I'm just kidding yeah
we've had it I've had it around four
times I've got mates that I got the
vaccine and they still got it four plus
times and it's just I mean don't you
think it helps you not die from it yeah
no I definitely agree with that I
definitely agree that it's got giv you
antibodies and then at the same time
they keep updating it it's like your
iPhone exactly they update the terms and
services yeah I
um I don't
um it's hard I'm not you didn't like it
I didn't like it I I'm not I'm not I'm
not
antisocial so I you said you're a t I'm
a little bit autistic yeah I don't but I
don't like staying at home I like being
with mates and
um but being at home when it came to um
Co it was um it was nice but you miss
your friends and only playing Xbox does
a certain amount of yeah your Madness
sets in and yeah you're just sick of
your family you want to murder them bro
want to see something crazy I bought an
AR-15 recently bought for 15 we don't we
don't have those in Australia really oh
cuz of that one Port Arthur Port Arthur
that's it yeah I'm surpris you know that
yeah everyone knows that in America B
Arthur um you know just slowly started
chipping away at your freedoms one Mass
one mass shooting um to weigh all our
guns 17 this year and it's only February
it's only February that's actually we
haven't had a mass shooting in a while I
think we should be proud of ourselves
for that that's pretty that's pretty
pretty extraordinary I'm I'm quite proud
of you guys when was the last mass
shooting you guys have had uh especially
in the school they're the most important
ones mass shooting I don't know man I
remember there was one at a mall and a
Korean family got got really right away
there was one orphan she got shot but
she's still alive unlike her family if
she was an orphan then it hurt cuz it
was a Korean family they're like human
beings like me I mean you're a cool
you're a cool Korean but if they're
orphans yeah you know who else died that
was Korean the the spa Shooters the guy
that went to all the brothel in Atlanta
shot up all the prostitutes really is
that a real thing yeah that happened did
someone go around like an insult he's
like nobody should have sex this is
immoral wow IM immoral did you hear
about the guy from New Zealand yeah
Christ Church yeah put up the numbers so
live in a in a Muslim country in a
Muslim um musk musk that's it and um
that was live streamed and we watched it
as freaking why why did you watch it it
was there so he he killed so many people
he killed a lot and then he um you see
them die I saw a lot of people die it
was um not nice to watch but it's one of
those things where like you can't really
not look you know yeah if it's just a
link exactly and you click on link how
did you get the link
It Gets Sent around because you guys are
so close to it New Zealand is pretty
much like you're Canada pretty much
that's exactly right New Zealand is our
Canada and we we again and US likes
Canada to a certain extent and we like
New Zealand to hands distance you know
like you guys have different accents it
sounds completely different yeah I can't
even tell we lock them but I can't tell
you can't tell yeah I can't tell you
can't tell no oh we can tell if you like
I can't it's I think Australian is more
like and New Zealand's like what just hi
there New Zealand is you can kind of you
can kind of hear it um we have this
thing in our um sport um Cod rugby
league if you hear them we have a lot of
new zealanders and a lot of um
Australians hey you want to come
over okay see you soon let me know when
you're you're here bye bye who was that
Juanita oh yeah nice so yeah we have new
zealanders and we have Australians in
the sport of uh rugby league and Rugby
Union yeah and if you hear them two talk
at the same time you can you can
definitely tell the difference but
Flight of the Concords yeah it's like
only if you hear them next to each other
but I heard you can tell by the way they
say o o o o o you got any o yeah right
we we o o what's o ice Aussies ice like
frozen water oh ice oce we say ice ice I
don't know if if they say i o o o yeah o
yeah what do you think about Lord of the
Rings I've never watched it before but
you know sh not Zealand yeah it's been
um hey I know they [__] the Sheep over
there but that's bad it it's um I mean
that's basically a flashlight for one
sheep you dream of over there um to get
yourself to sleep is one shape you
actually [__] well they actually shut
down very harsh for Co yeah they were
just bad as us but um it in reality it
um it was just because they were just
such a small island they were like as
soon as one one um Co um how would you
one case one as as soon as one Co case
came into
Australia the whole country shut down
only only took one and that's same with
Australia only took one to shut down the
whole country isn't it better to do that
than to wait and then shut down halfway
and then just have it I guess percolate
yeah when it came to shutting down it
um it uh a lot of repercussions came
along um
with the [__] with the shutdown yeah
um I don't know I guess being young and
wanting to go out it kind of it changes
my opinion in a certain extent I am my
past opinion I was kind of like oh this
is [__] yada yada y but at the same
time what else are they supposed to do I
supposed to just you know tag along and
just hope for the best they can't really
do that as a country I know Texas kind
of just um kept everything open mhm and
they they seem to do all right but who
knows if they even did it I mean they
the scenes in the hospital were pretty
horrific in El Paso yeah really yeah
like people dying vators and people just
wheezing to death and you can't do
anything but watch them die as lungs f
with liquid it's a touchy subject and if
I'm being completely honest I don't know
which side I want to really completely
be on I got I got both
vaccines mainly just because I wanted to
um go out and drink with my buddies
because it got to a certain extent where
um if you didn't have your vaccine you
weren't allowed to um go out you weren't
allowed to let the house I had a um a
manager back at home who um who wasn't
allowed to work certain days because of
the vaccine
so so he refused to get it and now it's
fine you just had to wait out maybe six
months yeah and then it was all over
there is no vaccine passport anymore no
there's no vaccine nobody asked you for
your covid test results that's I
actually went to a music festival and
they were like hey what's your we need a
recent covid test oh I have one from
three months ago how how long ago was
that this is like right after it was
happening yeah right and then I was like
here's this from six months ago or
whatever I like oh it's positive like h
it's probably not good yeah you want a
negative yeah you want a negative you
can't just get a test result it has to
be negative yeah that doesn't that's not
a thing anymore at least in Australia
like yeah neither is it I mean obviously
much more advanced than you and that
way we are you guys are far at in a lot
of
things yeah in um in sport especially I
think I think so you guys are pretty far
ahead
I mean Australia is the only country
where the most popular sport is
Australian football true we um we have
our AFL over there which is um our
American Football League I think that's
what the acronym is uhuh um where can't
just jump in the air and catch the ball
and kick the ball as far as I can and
that's where you get your NFL punters
from
nowaday all those [__] just [__]
yeah hunting [__] you know the you know
about the NFL yeah the National Football
League the National Football League we
have um you know the punters over there
we have um
Mitch uh wski I think his name is so do
they punt the ball when it's like
they're fourth and whatever and they
just want to get out of there or are the
punters the one that do the field goals
the punter is the one that does just
they kicking all it they kick it on
Fourth and whatever we don't we kick
field goals but we can kick um we can
punt we can punt we punt like a [__] we
can punt like a [__] that's it that's a
right [__] punt right there [__] you
know [__] punt is a um a good term for
um for when you don't like a woman and
you want to kick him right the cut oh
yeah that seems very literal we don't we
don't actually do it but um if you a lot
to put her right in the cut yeah that's
exactly right I've never wanted to do
that you've I there's been times where
you get up a bit upset and I feel like
the girls that you would do that to
would be the best at taking that I think
I think so too but you know supposedly
apparently getting K kicked in the [__]
is as bad as getting kicked in the balls
which I think is completely [__]
I've seen them react to getting K in the
C it's bad but it's not that and you
don't want to get kicked in the [__]
more than like the thigh or I don't know
depend cuz people do nasty leg kicks
when um when people get like a sock to
the
nuts it's way worse than it is getting a
suckable it's like the difference
between
childbirth and a kidney stone yeah I
think kidney Stone's worse I think now
with all the advanced technology it's um
it's sort of just they're I think
they're overreacting a little bit the
[__] the [__] the the the I'm not not
the women the the [__] that are the
like giving birth yeah they're um not
the it's like I I it's hard but now they
can you know get the steroid not the
steroids the um injections to kind of
numb the pain they just stop complaining
about that [__] if we got a numbing pain
for every time we got hit in the balls
we every man and their dog would take
that take that shot you're doing
steroids
exactly it's
um it's not a great feeling is it
no it's
not I
um I actually uh fought a guy and his
strategy was to kick me in the nuts
really yeah and I had baggy pants yeah
so it was kind of sagging so I caught a
lot of them in the SAG of the time cuz
that's how you used to dress back in the
early 2000s it's a big guy yeah but it
protected me protect my balls but the
thing is like he caught the tip of my
balls so my balls were like felt a
little little weird we have we have this
um technique in Australia called the scr
grip it's where you grab you grab
someone's balls and you twist it oh that
that's a deadly strategy if you're
really in some
trouble um usually we use that in our um
in our sport rugby league if you and if
you're getting a bit of a scrum and
you're getting a bit of a tackle and
you're not feel the vision is blocked
exactly and you grab you you go up and
grab and you [__] twist why you do
that uh I don't do it but some people it
seems like a tradition of Cruelty it's a
dog it's in in Australian qu dog act
it's uh not a cool thing to do but
people still do it it's kind of like
it's kind of like doing a helmet to
helmet I feel like cuz there's like a
like a forbidden thing like this is what
you do if you're going crazy and then
everyone who feels a little bit crazier
than normal is like okay now I get to do
this now no one intally does it unless
they're very bad people it's it's
probably like not good for like the
bloke you're doing it to you um you
really you must height them unless let's
do it he you're going to send him to the
doctor he's going to wear the Gown the
doctor's going to come in I'm sorry sir
there's no
more there babies available if you um if
you do that to someone I think you're a
cruel human being
it's um it's unnecessary it's very
unnecessary especially when you're
already running into each other head- on
head yeah um some people just do that
because they're um they're [__] and
they like they like to feel pain and if
you [__] we giving them this Avenue
we're like hey there's this thing don't
do it yeah but if it didn't exist they'd
be just be like stewing and they
wouldn't be able to express their
disgusting Parts but since it's already
started it's hard to put the cat in the
bag 100% And also the fact about the
fact is that um you can't to a certain
extent if um like we don't we cups like
people in football do yeah like we don't
wear the cups we don't wear any
protection down there it's just really
short shorts and they're very vulnerable
it's [__] easy to just go up and grab
them and twist them if you really want
to do it most people don't do it but um
if you had a ball two balls in your hand
what how bad do you think you can get to
the point where it just like pops and S
you could easily you could easily grab
them twist them and break them just if
they there with your hand with your hand
I don't think I could do that I think
that takes technique it's like yeah
that's that's exactly what you need you
just need grab twist so grab twist
before I've not done it but I've had it
done to me to a certain extent people
people [__] not talking about your
uncle my uncle did not um molest me when
I was younger um else did no um no
you're a golden child no one has
molested me which is um that's all that
a parent needs to do that means your
parents did their job they're done a
great
job and um I don't um here ju us here
you want to entertain the people yeah
sure
hello
hello good coming is going to let Anita
Han in I think I'm terrible with names
by the way and this is the first time
I've ever done a podcast hello how are
you you know anyone could be watching
this right now even from Australia and
um who knows if someone from Australia
right now from home is watching hello
everyone um the only person I've told
that I'm doing this right now is my
girlfriend
um and even even she probably what
doesn't even know the technology on how
to get onto this podcast right now so
this is um this is fun this is the first
time and having a great time I don't
know if I'm good at this or not but um
having a good old time I'm not checking
my phone until after because this is a
um this could be a very scary
repercussion um happening on to me but
who
knows um Hans is a cool
guy
hello hello hello
hello that way other
one
well here I'll go this what's the next
called
austral austr austral
yeah believe or
not are Quinn yeah Quinn
an w that's
right a terrible name so if I forget
your
name you
going you're from like a kind of a
throwaway
country yeah well we're we're you know
what are you a country for ants weit
we're a cool country we're actually the
only country that's fought with you guys
in every war so what choice did you have
you were no no choice at all if we
didn't fight with you we'd probably be
by China by now prison country that said
hey we'll go with whoever is winning
yeah yeah 100%
And like it's like the kind of situation
where they like two cigarettes at a time
I know and that's I like light
one are you visiting Austin are you I'm
visiting Austin I'm leaving uh on the
6th of February February and coming back
on the um the 15th of February
afterwards okay so you're going home for
like 4 days I'm going to Vegas Vegas
okay so you're not leaving the stat not
leaving the states but I'm leaving wait
wait wait what dates are you going to be
in Vegas what takes me to Vegas the
Super Bowl the Super Bowl cuz you give
such a [__] about the American Football
I love an American
weeaboo American football is somewhat
big in um Australia you know how like
Japanese dudes that are into or white
dudes that are into Japanese ship what
are you looking for
ju it's down underneath the table oh
[__] but down under can you put the it's
down under it's down under for the the
Super Bowl yeah down under we um we take
you like Taylor Swift no [__] no [__]
that [__] we we don't like Taylor Swift
what's your favorite part of American
football uh originally the the big hits
that you guys put on but um now the
sport in
what's Australia like I I have hooked up
with a guy from austral H up with the
from I hat it to know country damn it
really he said come over for a night cap
you know when I an old I did terminology
and I was like it's fine and then I
didn't I didn't talk to him after and
then two weeks later I wasn't enough
color when I heard he was just annoying
H that's a shame when and and dirty talk
with an Australian accident is isn't it
it's rough it's rough there's no way to
make that accent sexy uh no we got a
good accent we no you don't sounds a
little jovial it sounds like there's no
way to make an Australian accent sexy
not we 100% do have a good accent we
have a sexy accent no you don't 1,000%
no you
don't do you want me to lick you from
down on no I hate that we don't we don't
I it sounds like a question is it good
everything you say all the time sounds
like a qu I you want me to lick you from
down it sounds like a question all the
time is that a r your chest qu I'm not
I'm not going to lie I want to suck his
dick like right now like it's not a
contest I hate the Australian ACC the
thing is that that one experience though
the one experience is enough for me to
like you want me to like you from Down
Under no I got a mayor that's coming to
he actually said that a mayor you say I
is she a redhead a mate we I got a mate
that's coming from Australia right um he
I'm going to meet him in Vegas that's
when are you going to meet them in Vegas
what's the date um they're from the 6th
to the 13th of
February for the Super Bowl I'll be I
I'll be in Vegas from March March oh I'm
not there what are you doing in Vegas
I'm doing some shows
there show you're gonna do like the
scene there you're GNA do the all the
shows I'm going do all of it do you know
some a lot of people there yeah i' I've
kissed some people in the cheeks for
some spots that's all it takes damn a a
cute little Swift kiss on the cheek I
need start kissing I know get out there
that's all you to do you just say hey
just kid I'm gonna be in this city I
already suck Tony's [__] do
K kissing thing there's a [__] on the
table kissing thing everyone does a
kissing thing
nothing thing to be on it to earn it
that's
crazy you know in Korea we call kissing
kissing we don't say poo poo is for
babies and kids so we we use the word
kissing kiss kiss kiss did you kiss it's
like kissing we don't have a word for it
on our own we took the American English
word yeah right isn't that weird and sex
we say sex we don't have a word for sex
words right now sexa I like that yeah I
have a linguistic Ser
interesting what's your cat's name Milly
ohita you're the first one to make that
one what's your cat's name this podcast
Millie Millie this is Brian Simpson's
cat it's cute cat can I ask you a
question yes would you rather
have worms for
nipples okay
or slugs for toes slugs for toes worms
for nipples slugs for to don't crush
that cat leave that cat the [__] alone H
he leave that hey Hans leave the cat
alone
a just can't have him touching the
electronic affected by the worms of toes
is not your Mobility yeah so like can
you walk as well as you you're fine it's
just there's just [__] worms for or
slugs slugs sorry slugs slug slugs so
can can you walk normally with the Slugs
for toes because you know go to Gold Gym
I go to I I have been there yes which
golds do you go to I went to the one in
Austin today downtown Austin downtown
Austin you bought that hat I I thought
it was a cool
hat you said I need I need these [__]
to know sorry you said I need these
[__] to know I just
enjoyed I I have a question how easy is
[__] with this like Australian accent I
hate Australian you hate it I don't like
an English I hate English I hate
Australian and I [__] a man with your
your opinion is valid but the first
night I was here it was very easy yeah I
would I didn't because I have a
girlfriend back at home but I if I
wanted to i' definitely oh my God
but she has an Australian accent she was
at back at home she well my girlfriend
back at home or the girl the girl here
like there was a chick here but your
girlfriend back at home has an
Australian accent very [__] cool
here's the thing about an Australian
accent is I think the Australian accent
on a woman hot as [__] yeah the
Australian accent on a man you know I
think you just had one bad experience
with the BL and no no here's the thing
is I've met and especi Austin Austin a
session in it
um place is I've met so many girls with
the Australian accient it's always hot
when a girl has an
Australian yeah she's bad I I you know
you could really flip a coin I don't
know I I I don't I don't really see it
that way I don't think so uh your
percentage I don't like women at all but
it would be very difficult not to
scissor in Australian sure yeah that's
all right Isa Fisher who's Isa Fisher
she dates Sasha bar and Cohen I think
they're married now I love them I love
them no power couple she's man that was
and behaves like Vince vaugh then freser
like his that's my sex my sexuality is
Vince vaugh I was
vce I was on mushrooms whenever I saw
Bruno for the first time and I was like
passed out and then I woke up to him and
like a little Asian with like a
champagne bottle like up his [__] and
then he was picking up the tiny Asian
and serving it into champagne flu and I
was like am I this high or did like is
this an actual like film like did it
it's a film it's a film it's a film is
it for my film something crazy my mom
I'll have you pour champagne out of your
hours my mom loves pour champagne out
ofs my mom is an insane person do you he
says I'm a really nice guy do you guys
call that a buttchug as well in America
is a butt chug I'd love to know way you
put alcohol up your ass and you you chug
it what my thing is Australia I don't I
don't need to hear a goddamn thing from
y'all because Australia why is she going
at you so hard right now what the [__]
okay my biggest thing is Australia so
turned on
Australia like built on
like like just disgusting people
Australia is just built off prisoners
you can look like
from you said I guess it'll be mean to
the indigenous people
like austral built on worthless
prisoners why they so me Nepali and like
indigenous people why we M them have the
most [__] accent no I'm I'm I'm
being [__] just Australian sounds
like Southern person the Australian
accent sounds like if a southern person
and a Scottish person had a baby and
then that baby had a stroke yeah that's
probably accurate do babies have strokes
uh I I don't think so but you know if
they did we'd probably sound like them
so Scottish and American accent or like
the Scottish accent in general is just
like like we like I have been wondering
why my baby sounds Australian when' Got
To Train Your Dragon when we when I hear
a s accent I think I'm fat bastard so I
don't I don't think I don't think we
sound exactly like it chill accent
is back I my personal opinion there is
nothing against you I think I don't I
wouldn't care either way oh you wouldn't
care either way that's good that um I
think that you had one bad experience
with an Australian and watch Love on the
Spectrum love on the Spectrum isn't that
crazy that we got [__]
guys because you guys are kind show of
all time you're kind to your people and
you also love Whimsy and like quirkiness
yeah that's like a character trait I
feel like the entirety of Australia will
agree with me Summer High tie best
Australian show ever it's a fantastic
table Kath and Kim is my favorite show
Kim is
[__] I'm going to go we're going to
go to dance lessons and but other than
that Australian accent
is so you've watched Kath and Kim and
have been chill with the accent
listening yeah but then you [__] one guy
with an Australian ACC who's Catherine
Kim Catherine Kim it's cther Kim Kim is
she a TV personality it's it's like a
like early 2000s it's AIA it's like
friends it's like our office it's like
an older woman and her daughter so it's
a sitcom it's the office okay yes thank
you for is it a Korean no okay just a
girl named K no but on summer high high
there's a rich Australian
um private school I thought it was
Korean cuz said Kim it's like why would
they have a show about
Korean why is this show about me I think
is like Kim Kim for Kimber kimbery I
think it is no it's Kim Kim Kimber hey
Kimber
Kim Kim what's your favorite
country my favorite country UK your
favorite country UK what's yours ah
great question um quickly quickly you
I'm I'm not giving my answer quickly my
favorite like favorite country to to
what extent though hey can you give me
uh your impression of like a Southern
accent like an American southern accent
American southern accent I've been I've
been making fun of your accent whole I
can't I can't do accents that's the
thing
he I'll give you an example right yeah
I'll make fun of your accent all right
and then you make all right well we're
going to Gatlinburg okay hey we're here
too by the way hey what's your name
again one more time first name lucky
yeah lucky lcky lcky is the way that
Americans was my Ukrainian grandma's
name that she gave way too many
Percocets to and he died yeah well is
that your government name is lucky my
government name is lucken which is GIC
for Matthew but um okay so Matthew ma no
we
have know L patter said gay Patterson
what Lan Patterson he's a comedian gay
like more
like gay I
familiar but yeah um whatever look yeah
we I can't do an accent can't do a
country accent I stop doing accents okay
so I'm going to pretend like we're
getting engaged in Gatlinburg okay you
got to prot why are he so fascinated
with this guy I thought you hated much
you just let us do our improv moment and
you you've been talking to him for the
last 10 minutes yeah you want to play
the violin while the Titanic goes down
anyway all right it's cuz I'm
Asian right there were no Asians in the
Titanic wait is our
viol they the math would have been
better but anyway well what's the uh
dude that's [__] up there I don't
think there were any Asians in the
Titanic I it wasn't in the mov minor
first of all there's no geometry in the
Titanic so it was just all just ideas
and
words so what's the uh General thought
on uh the Titanic do you guys see the
movie or I did and I I'm so mad at her
she could have been Rich she's like a
big blue diamond all she had to do is
just like you know give a little suuck
it up yeah I would have [__] like
loved that like yeah I would have gone
over it yeah but didn't they make him
unlikable he had a very Stern expression
he was heartless and cold he was kind of
calculated and oh yeah l i i lik when
when he grabbed a kid and he was
like I have a child I have a child he
like escaped I come to Titanic
when come here poor child Titanic the
main the main people they wanted to save
were like women and children oh yeah
that are pretty much worthless survival
Instinct wise like for me let it's like
hey you have to be the one survive I
would be like looking I probably he was
so [__] that they considered him a
woman they're like
clearly honestly
winlet baby you're 140 lbs
that's not skinny but you there was an I
used to think about killing myself and I
really like would like admired her like
in the outfit like about to jump off the
boat I was like damn hey there's one
thing I myself I'm going to painful way
to die as long as I'm skinny enough to
uh withstand one door but I could still
be
like drown [__] to a man that took my
virginity when I was chubby dude can you
imagine like f Got Away on a door while
you know C sang hey goodbye fat ass can
you imagine being on with like a friend
of me it's like a girl that like you
have to pretend that you like but you
hate and I like oh no the boat is s hey
PR face bad ass can take anywhere like
whatever people were trying to say that
I pushed her but it was like it was
maybe that's why Leonardo DiCaprio won
date a girl that's older than 25 it's
because it's something had a pretty face
and a fat ass maybe he's just judging
them for their ability to stay on a
door do you think that was enough for
room on that door d I was going to say
like huge a movie they can make the door
as small as want an antique door like a
plank like but it was like a whole ass
like queen
size a suit don't wor they could do
sorry you can do a little Ki just put
your put your vitals above the door and
your legs can be in the water both of
you you guys can kick your way to
Freedom yeah literally and she had a
whistle and a [__] fat diamond and
she was just like sorry yeah I feel so
bad for Kate Winslet I'm so sh at most
145 didn't know she had it cuz it was in
the pocket and the jacket I doubt no she
there's a scene where she looks oh I
think she had more diamonds it's like
how how the [__] did she like go through
I've used that sug before Oh I just
didn't know yeah wa D hey hey the poor
guy got away so Quinn what's going on
poy died fatty got away on a door are
you from bakut or donbas or are you
speaking English no ukra Ukraine the
cities donbas no or the you know Crimea
uh probably like uh I I don't know [__]
like uh
are you like well vers on
Ukraine is that desperate for [__] he's
Asian he's incredibly I love the
Ukrainian accent it's one of my
faves suck my dick I make you suck my
dick you sound like
Russian I used to like tattoo a lot
they're just the saddest sounding one
there just like please running water
yeah please give us more javelin
missiles we must kill the the Russians
the Russians we need more money we for
missiles I think Ukraine and Korea can
have like this like certain like I I can
say can I get for you in Russian it
sounds pretty scary you speak like four
languages
though I know it's like bless you do you
need a
Tish um no yeah I I speak French Spanish
Galan what's Galan it's from
Northwestern Spain it's like a k Port
Gala Galia Galia yeah is that near
Barcelona no Barcelona is like
southwestern
Southeastern and Galia is Northwestern
what did do you learn these languages uh
my family's um Basque so they're from
North uh are they
separ um yeah you know what they don't
say it but like um they moved to Mexico
which is where I was born and in
Mexico um they never talked about
politics or anything but when then we
did a second move to the United States
in the United States my have an American
cousin that played football and they
would salute the American flag with a
Mexican hand gesture which is like a
flat hand over T what you do when you do
bull fighting yeah and I was like huz
America I always thought like you silly
gooses like that's the American this is
one
mve I know it's like you're loading up
[__] spring it up I didn't realized
until like way later when I actually
took like politics in Latin America in
University I was like oh [__] they're
being like Cy and they're like yes this
is how we salute your flag this how we
salute
like remember when we were kids and we
go like this to say you're
[__] yeah that was the
and then Carlos Mania came around and
then he like
Po no I know I saw a comic like steel
that from Carlos man and San Antonio and
I was like yeah well he just
opened I feel like if you're stealing
from Carlos Mania that's yeah that's
Karma who is that Carlos Mania is a
Honduran comedian is he funny his name
is Ned he is funny he's also Bobby Lee
he's is that's not thean confronted him
okay so that is the guy yeah right I've
seen that video yeah the best video I I
did that in San Antonio laugh out loud
there was a a guy I won't say his name
because he's he's not that bad of a guy
but like he was doing Louis CK's bits
verse like word for word he was like
yeah and I was on a plane and there was
babies on the plane and it's like it
wasn't it was that whole bit and I was
like Lou CK I yelled it I was like
that's [__] Louis CK and then after
he got off of the mic he got banned from
that like really venue yeah and I was
like oh [__] that was me CU I was like I
heckled him but I I will only Heckle you
if I know you're stealing something I
don't know if that's that seems fair so
that's a big thing in the comedy
community obviously is you're not a
comic no I'm not a comic I'm a comic fan
a 21-year-old Australian that met Shane
Gillis and was friends with him and
friends to a certain sent I met him
twice but I'm um he's a 21-year-old a
I'm a big I'm a big fanan who had sex
with Chen yeah I mean kiss them on the
cheeks I'm a big I'm a big fan but um
when it comes down to um I know that
ceiling is obviously not right when it
comes down to
um doing um material but yeah I don't
know the um the ins and outs when it
comes down to um well well the reason
it's so shitty is that you work on
something for so long like whether
you're famous or not famous or whatever
it's worse when you're not famous and
you like have a great bit and then like
somebody takes it and uses it like on
stage and you're like what me either way
you're not supposed to steal jokes yeah
feel is [__] shitty that's why I'm
not not bash be like that's [__] so
and so like it could have been an open
micer I would have been like that that
is Quinn's joke [__] you like like
standing up for people did Riley
Gilmore's joke on kill Tony someone did
nordan Shelby's joke on kill Tony
Riley's joke on
yeah damn I don't know which episode but
have any of you guys gotten Dr stolen
before where you've had to had a joke
stolen before but it was like it got
called out pretty quick yeah [__] yeah
and how did that feel when you when you
heard it good cuz I'm like wow y'all
think that's that's funny yeah that's
good it's a compliment that's a good he
got called out quick that's a good um
attitude did anybody ever stolen your
jokes yeah someone posted it on Twitter
and they got called out immediately oh
[__]
yeah did I is my joke about birth
control no I don't know what joke it was
maybe it was about birth control and uh
being pro lifee it's like you're micro
doing
abortions oh yeah I remember that one is
that is that still banned here in Texas
abortion abortion yeah it's still
been yeah I mean why do you need to have
an abortion unless you're having lots of
sex which is
bad I uh I'm like a super pro lifee I
think like you should be able to abort
at like like you know like 48 months
like is that kid annoying like so you're
pro-choice not actually I don't give a
[__] like yeah you said Pro lifee did I
say pro life I said you said Pro you
said pro life and then you stated to say
48 months you can just yeah that's very
Pro death that's not even pro-choice
yeah I was trying to be a silly and
[__] it up I mean when kids are zero
years old they don't even name them in
some cultures cuz they don't think
they're fully human yet that's really
good Insight I didn't know that it's
kind of crazy that's kind of [__] up
yeah it's so inappropriate that's a
human life it's born you got to take
take care of it not like the Spartans
who would throw them off a cliff can you
smoke regular things in here or just
weed just weed so [__]
up would do you want to have a smoke
break maybe yeah why smoke clove
cigarettes cuz I'm
alternative [__] you know I did get a
little chilly you're so
cool I'm a CO girly you're so cool I
thought I was on the Frozen Banks of Bak
moot
yeah is it my my Stern
glare the
IC yes
yeah zinski
my you know it's funny that during World
War II the Russians just kept getting
surrounded and taken prisoner and they
just kept losing and losing like butt
stuff is fun
they just got [__] by the Nazis but
then they [__] came back cuz butt
stuff is cool everyone loves butt stuff
so do you think you have a lot of
inherited Trauma from World War II from
butt stuff
no Great Patriotic
War
no I think the Russians the Russians
defeated the Nazis air fryer and I'm
sure my grandma is like I fled for
nothing K Kachi
perog that's Polish peris I'm sure my
grandma fled Ukraine in the dead of
night and it was like like a
Jew gave up and was like uh I'm going to
flee Ukraine in the dead of night and my
my my great granddaughter she's going to
make progis in a dead of night and borch
and like all all of this she's going to
make progis and an airly and bourch and
an insta pot why are all immigrants so
proud of their food who's like man maybe
had
maybe American food is too and just used
to this
food shove they always have to shove
their food down our throat like our
cheeseburgers and Thai food I thought
cheeseburgers like Texas barbecue is
that
yeah dude dude no parois in an air fryer
just [__] fried potatoes and then
borch and a insta pot is like like a
beet soup B
oh yeah B Russian yeah yeah and it just
like Ukrainian cold it you can serve it
warm too it's just B in and it's like a
it's beets and then what what is
Australian food so we have uh chicken uh
so there's chicken s WABE WABE no we
don't eat WABE so I love WABE I'd
[__] kill you in Cold Blood if you
told me you at a
w Roo's Modern Life up with W I've eaten
kangaro emu and um have punched a
kangaroo dead in the [__] face I've
never because you'd lose no not if
you're quick you're saying you're a
[__] honestly I'd kill a kangaroo think
I've seen pictures of these buff
Kangaroos and some of them can get one
onone with a kangaroo kangaroo wouldn't
know what to do with my li they um
kangaroo wouldn't know what to do with
my left the thing about kangaroos is
that if you punch them in the head yeah
and you can cuss them they're taals um
react to that and that will keep them
the the taals will keep themselves
balance um without making them collapse
so whether or not well why do so many
people in Australia have autism have you
seen love on the Spectrum I have it's um
it's from the kangaroo make eye contact
with the kangaroo and see where it goes
yeah it doesn't go well but you were we
were talking about food earlier yeah so
like our food like we we have the
chicken titel which is originally German
but then we add uh sauce and bacon to it
and it's a chicken
py what what's the sauce a chicken
parmesan so like marinara sauce and
bacon plus cheese it's chicken Pam we
have a chicken P Pana yeah damn that
sounds good I made I flooded with a
flood and we made chicken pesan H but
but what did you do that's not a real
art form it's not we don't really have
an make eye contact as an Australian
person you can't I've seen level this I
curiosity um Hans what what are your
favorite I want to know everybody's
favorite Comics like what's your
favorite Ryan Mitch hadberg dude I love
Mitch Mitch H what's your favorite Mitch
joke I used to do drugs I still do but I
used to too what's your who's your
favorite comedian my favorite Mitch
hyber joke is a I don't have a
girlfriend um but I do have a girl that
matter you heard me say that it's a good
one
Mitch I don't know Mitch the [__] up
shut the [__] up I I your favorite Coman
my favorite comedian is probably Louisa
I have um Louie I know it's a classic
but um Louie when he when he beats off
in front of a girl don't
know he asked I love that beat off in
front of me I
love he was he was my it's called ladder
climbing he was one of the first
comedians he was my first non like he
was my first inappropriate comedian sort
like I one of the first comedians I like
my parents got me on to when I was a kid
was uh Jim Gaffigan when I was a kid
[__] he's awesome but then and Jerry
Seinfeld but um I'm not big fans of them
anymore Lou is my favorite comedian he
was the first what was your last strw
Jerry my first uh last time last time I
saw Jerry s was I was probably like 14
in Australia that was your last draw was
the 14-year-old when he was 33 really he
was Phil it was 16 or 17 Scott Filmore
has did the best bit of like a woke uh
Jerry Seinfeld episode where he's like I
don't know
like a woman May has a Painis I don't
know and like
Jerry they have penises now like it was
like George and Jerry but like in like a
woke like culture and like Scott Filmore
was like doing this for like Michael
fractor on six and it was the funnyest
[__] [__] it was he's like spot on
like my my impressions are like dog [__]
of them he was so [__] funny it
was
the is not very
um that's that's pretty
slow what are we going to do about
these
I don't know what pronouns are my mine
is has he done I'm not entirely sure has
he done setup since that one little
incident that he had Kramer N word yeah
no hasn't I think that's fair a lot more
balls comedy than that and then and then
South Park came in with the have you
seen the South Park episode I've not
seen is there South oh my God so there's
a South Park episode where Stan the like
the dad on South Park is on um like I
don't know like uh some game show yeah
and then like it's like these are people
that annoy you and it's npace
G um RS and then like he says the N word
and then it's it's nag I don't know if I
should say this and it's actually
naggers I'm say like people who nag
naggers but he says N word that's
beautiful that's a South do everything
right they they're so funny they're
hilarious they're one of the last real
comedy shows of um the world like sou
South something I can like sit down and
watch and I liked book a Mormon which
one book a Mormon
yeahum hello my name is Elder Sam and I
have what the [__] is
happening sing B [__] [__] it's such a
beautiful song okay fine keep going
from start to finish
and I don't like it you're doing great I
think you did great you're doing okay
and I don't like it I enjoyed it I'm
hitting the notes and you're not even
the kind ofion that uses like pitch's
language
[Music]
like this is a lot what's your favorite
race my favorite race question um indd
500 why I like when I like when they go
to Bristol Tennessee because I usually
getting for free that's my favorite R
Bristol this so loud have you ever brist
that's my favorite race now have you
ever been to American uh motor motor
event I've never been to American it's
so loud it's unbelievably loud it's like
the Earth arm wrestle right now arm
wrestle oh [__] you want to go do you
think I'm just doing this this hey this
is so hot arm wrestle me right now
[__] I'm not very strong so yeah I can
tell I'm been drinking a Bud Light dude
you made Hans spill his like sorry white
claw you made Hans Spritz on himself
from his thermal you made had a white
claw and a thermal like I thought it was
sou but it it smells like black Cher
have you seen those um arm wrestle
videos where people break their break
their arms from like Ping too hard and
it's very common in Australia where
people um break their arms from arm
wrestling yeah cuz you have to [__]
do I have a little fantasy because I
used to hey in Australia we usually we
usually break arm and have we have this
we have this one show called from the
eucalyptus euy one show called The Footy
Show back in Char it's canceling out hey
we're so high off the lucal lipus that
we just break each other's
arm yeah and one time two ex X NRL
players were doing an arm wrestle and
that's why D talk sounds so not sexy
what's um what's that ligament in your
arm where um I thinking your elbow no
not your elb your um UCL I think e
no's
it's the C it's the CL in your elbow and
um anyway you could if you see watch the
video I
can yes no I got a funny I'm really good
at this you do a good accent I'm not
going to lie I know um you can see the
full you get cyia from a
man we get AIA pick it up Prett who's
your favorite character on Summer
Heights High have you seen Rocko's
Modern Life Rocko no I haven't
he's favorite um character I have not
watched Tomah High Tai in a a j j is up
there um but from Jonah Jonah from Tonga
is my favorite Jonah and then there's Mr
G Mr G is [__] is Mr J you do you know
Mr J yeah yeah oh
you [__] it's a great show have you arm
wrestled W you arm wrestled w
wrestle to W you want to yeah we're for
sure we have to make eye contact which
that's one thing I love in the Spectrum
one one thing that charans can't do
apparently so yeah if they got they're a
little dizzy with the tizzy the sun is
so bright tzy on your guy on my guy on
your guy okay on one two three go
there's a scene with Mr G where
he's he's like he's getting his show
ready and are you trying I'm trying oh
that's good so so he's getting it good
thought setting feminism back so far I
gave up you know what you're stronger
than I thought you would be that's
nothing that's nothing offensive at all
that's what my uncle said too and you
know what she was a sign maill at Birth
so like what's your what's your gender
my gender no is that a you have to ask
nowadays no you don't have to ask that
you know isn't I um I I signed up bir I
always ask people I was um booking to a
flat the other day M that [__] that
[__] I was booking into a flat the
other day and there was only two options
for gender which was pretty pretty crazy
there was only female and male for
gender gender that's what a time we live
in from I have a I have a bit that I'm
working on it's called an extreme
Publican gend extreme Republican gender
reveal party and it's like at this kind
of gend Ral party they just like grab
the baby and put it up and they just
pull the diaper
down there you go there you go let's
have a look and it's take a look at this
baby look at it I like the Hogwart [__]
the but like at least they don't put it
in their mouth like the
go no cic Jews a rabbi G little weenies
in the talk about a gender reveal they
suck baby yeah they suck the blood after
the circumcision that's a real thing
what the [__] is that it's a very
extreme Jewish thing I'm That Kind of
extreme Jewish thing sucking baby dicks
if I bad enough for a man [__] all
right a man are you regular Jewish are
you like one of those
extreme blood off your circumcision
scar I mean you know Catholicism we we
drink
BL juice and wine you don't suck baby
dick Jewish Jew blood you know I suck
his dick I me me too D Jesus is hot you
could suck anyone's dick it'd have to
been I'll suck any man's dick with a man
bun that's one crew and he Jesus did he
definitely at least he at least put it
in a bun once at least once he had a
ribbon at he had loaves of bread but he
also had and a high pain tolerance he
had Buns of Steel
hey a man but a high pain tolerance and
he loved
[__] yeah he did you know like B freak
I've never seen a fat Jesus so like you
know have you ever seen Korean Jesus
yeah from 21 Jump Street no no no
there's another Korean Jes each it was
before 21 Jump Street and he's just this
like jacked he looks like John Cena on
the cross you got to look up Korean
Jesus he's like
like I've we can all look up Korean
Jesus Jesus is uh whatever race you want
him to be is there like a Ukrainian
Jesus you know Jesus drone as long as
Jesus is over six foot I'm G to suck his
dick like I don't give f j six too but
if if he's below six foot I'm converting
to Islam like he was alive in the 2000s
Muhammad probably wasn't six feet
tall true but
a prophet you're only believing in
religions from people that are tall so
you're like a Scientologist or Ki is
Jack okay show show Georgia Institute of
Technology yeah yeah it's that one okay
look how F mechan Jack look how sexy
Kanan Jesus like he's a break dancer he
looks racially
ambiguous never seen a Korean guy that
jacked before he's so jacked he looks
like John Cena he does like yeah John
Cena he's got quad when did you go to
buy I went to buy uh this morning I um I
went to Dallas last night and um well
yesterday rather and um was driv on the
way on the way home I went to bies for
the first time [__] do a country
accent right now do a country accent
country accent how wa like from his
country no like from my country there's
there's like bar there is country then
you do flish I'm try a sentence and then
you're going to repeat it country can I
choose the country hey hey do you want
to go to Dollywood with me and my
friends tomorrow do you want to go to
Dollywood with me and my friends
tomorrow is that pretty good you sound
like an imposter imposter you want to go
with me and my friends tomorrow you
sound like boom hey y' you want to burn
some crosses and you need like be
like let him do it Heidi yes want to go
to the Mount sorrow do it do it hey
y'all you want to go to mount tomorrow
is that that's making fun of you hey y
you want go to the mountains tomorrow
but the Australian accent is like a
madeup accent it's every accent is made
up that's I have a the Australian accent
is a um is a relaxed version of the
British
accent very
relaxed the point of autism a southern
oxen is an extremely slow down version
of English o that the way that
Southerners speak now is closer to
William Shakespeare's English than the
how British people speak right now
really it is I makes sense like for
example though the word gay gay is a
very popular Australian like oh G mate
how are you gay came for oh good day
mate like good day sir good day sir that
may I have another and then um and then
the Brit the
British the British um convicts that
came from um from England were like oh
good day good day and good day good day
good day mate and then it good day mate
it's slowly it slow transitions into a
different accent to do you guys use any
Aboriginal words or did you guys just
totally extinguish their culture uh we
we Lo [__] that [__] hey we we like okay
if I'm being honest we like them over
there but
um we do we do like them over there but
it's like what they're just rubbing
sticks together they didn't even build
Huts
dude racist but like in a funny way yeah
like on that on that show summer hi Tai
like the the theater Professor like is
like running a show and he's watching
like the kids dance in high school and
he goes I thought black people were
supposed to have rhythm and that's like
one of the funniest lines I [__] like
Australia um we we we love our um our
like um ancestors like our um your first
Nations our first Nations like you guys
have your Indians or your n
native Amer reservation pigs so I don't
know how s how I don't know how much you
guys like them but we love them you love
them they're all dead so
he's we um they're pretty good at um
sport as well so um we let them play the
rugby league and oh yeah they um we do
this thing called uh maues which is the
New Zealand um yes of course native New
zealanders versus the native ums
Australia the the K oh my God why do you
make them fight each other like that
yeah it's it's weird now the who's going
to be our favorite the kwis versus the
you get a bone the kwis and they um they
verse it's like the um the the Pro Bowl
and they they they just fly to the death
the I don't know football that well it's
like the NBA All Stars it's like the NBA
it's like the the Home Run Derby in uh
pretty much we became we we used to not
be woke we used to do the whites versus
the aboriginals and then we became work
and instead what's what your opinion on
Love on the Spectrum um fight the kiwis
I think love on the spectrum is um
pretty [__] funny it's a show it's a
good concept people that can't make eye
contact and can't make conversations
you've not looked me in the eyes one
time I have looked in you the I I'm not
saying that I don't have autism but I
can look you on the eyes to a certain
extent count it down can't me in the
face one two three four five fascinating
podcasting there's a guy on love in the
spectrum that like he's he's kind of hot
there's a few that i' type you know what
like i' love dinosaurs too me too I love
to hear about who doesn't love dinosaurs
like I guess there's some [__] this guy
has no luck he literally went on a date
with a girl who has downs and she
rejected him American version I was like
no no no the Australian version I was
like baby like watch
jur I'm not that fascinated by the
process of dating you ever been to the
Austin Botanical Garden well wait would
you guys date like cuz it's about to
date somebody with autism no because
autism hey I do open mics the SP is
called Tinder the spectrum is so large
that you can't even tell in some cases
yeah like I would date like somebody
with autism over somebody who like
genuinely loves like Nickelback like
yeah that's fair I should have a show
about that because on never you know
what you like din dinosaurs but he's
[__] [__] Lally yeah like dating
with douchebags like two people with
awful
music I I believe what's a good show
autism or douchebag you get to choose I
choose autism because
douchebags douchebags are selfish
100% And I would need a pressure one
ones that like like like the hugs with a
lot of like tightness and pressure they
usually the down not a non touchy one
like it's like had to be a bit um on the
Spectrum it's um
itce obviously it's um he's just in all
the it's okay to be like girls in the
specials I guys it's pretty normal to be
on the Spectrum it's okay
suck dicks you're not going to catch it
well if you make eye contact and pop a
boner there's nothing wrong with you
just see you got a nice fat some good
teeths if you look at a girl with with
baby blows and you pop a boner it's
pretty
normal unless she's in a nickel back
unless
up any guys into nickel I don't even
know who Nick is no it's you're lying
hey you're lying thing is about um I
don't even know who nickel back is I
don't lying if you you song If you put a
Nick buug song on I'll probably know
what it is but I don't
know know that you know what it is but
I'm not going bend over for it you know
B why are you doing the accent how does
that help you
describe you're just marking him to his
face
nowas good at it accent say
anything you don't know me Tony H oh
really oh yes I do know
Jason fun a funny I he was
on before he's very funny he's um he's
the gay skateboarder isn't he he's yeah
well he's like he likes everything he
likes everything and then like he like I
guess got molested as a kid who hasn't
man who has getting ly he like Jason hey
cry a river cry a r Jason ens was like
he had a podcast for like years on serus
radio and he's like really tight with
like Tony Hawk and then Tony Hawk
whenever he was a kid Matt Jason Ellis
and he was like dude I it was so strange
being in Australia cuz um I was just
getting Fame and everyone's like hey
Tanny let me sign your dick or like sign
my dick and he was like what the [__]
hey tny can you sign my C then they were
talking about their deck like they're
like they're like tny into Hippie Hollow
no what's Hipp that's where people are
topless no Hippie Hollow is where you
can to be full balls out you get to be
naked on the beach balls out never heard
of it and it's in Austin right yeah okay
my my friend Noel I love Hippie Hollow I
grew up with a girl named Noel walls who
um ended a uh going on Saturday Night
Live she was a cast member and um then
she did Master of n with the Zas and sor
and then she made her own film called Mr
Roosevelt it's like on Netflix and I did
like
some no but she filmed she they went to
Sleepy H or Hipp Hol Hippie Hollow and
in I remember in that movie they went to
Hippie Hollow and they like they like
all got naked and there's like a scene
where I love Hippie Hollow Dude I love
Hippie Hollow why it's just nice cuz
there's no needles or dogs or babies cuz
it's open to sexuality and people are
free to express them
and sure but it's like you pay $8
everyone leaves you the [__] alone and
you can have your titties out it's great
you go to Hipp be Hollow you pay $8 and
there's no dogs there there's no needles
you just go there you can bring your own
alcohol and then you can just be there
naked and everyone leaves you the [__]
alone and people do you ever
socialize no cuz so you just go there to
just show your tits to people but not to
anybody because go in there I go to
Hippie Hollow and I pay my $8 and I go
in there with my Twisted teeth I come
out there titties and clam out and I
mind my business someone comes up there
and they're like hey can you spray this
on me and I go how about you rotten hell
for a turn like yelling at people
confronting them they come out to me
they're like hey can you spray sunscreen
on my back I'm like how about you rot in
hell for eternity actually happened yes
they come up to me they're like hey can
you spray my back I'm getting burnt I'm
like you should have you ever talked to
someone there that you liked and had a
great conversation with no so why do you
go to this place because everyone leaves
me alone and you can be mean go to Mars
then but clearly you can't be at bars
with my titties out but clearly people
aren't leaving my my titties and my clam
but people clearly AR economy what are
people leaving you alone in this place
they leave you alone if you set them
straight okay all right that's every
place though she she
fashion like devil horns out of her Bush
they come out here they come out like
hey can you spray on my lower back I'm
like I'll call your wife you fugo I like
nude I think there's a freedom to it I
think it's expression I think it's a
thing did you get to connect with other
humans you don't to step on a needle
have to wear deodorant I don't oh dude
I'm so jealous of that Koreans like
naked one
I have you have teenager have a genetic
mutation where they don't have to
X-Men
X body odor they're the of Indians we're
evolved to live in tight space I guess
Indians should be too but I guess they
just ignore it no they're very smelly we
um we have a lot of them in Australia
they they smell I think it helps us not
catch diseases or something what
diseases Corona virus yeah one one of
them help actually made it worse like I
can't smell the Corona on him no sense
um but yeah I think nudity is cool
because so much of the time we're
covering up our bodies and to just be
like okay [__] it we're not going to do
this it's fun to like break the rules it
is I think people should be able to do
it and it like if there's a certain
place where people can do it and it's
legal it's fine go ahead I think it
should be fine you shouldn't have even
have money for it if it's it's a be we
have a lot of we have a lot of new bites
in Australia some
moneyed I think you should pay money
were your family okay so like my family
didn't give a [__] about like uh nudity
or anything so like I remember but
you're from Spain yeah they're like when
I went to Spain I was titties out in
Spain I was going to say like like we
would be in the bath like as little kids
and like our ants and stuff would come
in like take a piss and just like full
Bush out just
like and like it was like no big deal
and wasn't until you remembered it yeah
I remembered it but it wasn't like more
morbid like and then in the United
States was like oh my God J Abus I went
to Spain with my like
exboyfriend and it was like it was like
one of those things just like everyone
was titties out and like you to think
about the boyfriend was it a girlfriend
he engaged is he fans now no he's
engaged now but like um it was one of
those things like everybody titties out
and like I love being titties out if I
can like cuz who gives a [__] so that's
I love Hippie Hollow cuz it's like who
gives a [__] well we have like these
like conversations now like um like in
in like an American environment like me
and my sister's like like my sister's
like isn't it cool that like Mom has
like pink nipples like she's so white
like but it's like it's so weird because
like if this was like Americans talking
about it like you would [__] mom or what
like a binary it's either you're super
sexual or you're not sexual at all in
Spanish culture it's like oh our mom's
nipple sort of like a gray area in
between nothing like we're not we don't
want to [__] our mom but it's like yeah
her nipples are pink like that's weird
weird talk about it and stuff it down
into your head it's just an observation
yeah it's an observation and then like
i' like I one of my uncles had a really
big dick and I remember like being like
a little kid and he would just like you
changes like [__] like underwear and
[__] in front of us he was just
bragging gu is actually a pervert dude
he like he like he would like traffic
people and [__] I was like traffic them
what yeah he was like um this dick no
like um they lived in Mexico he's he's a
married an uncle he's like Mexican and I
remember whenever like um I I toured
doing like improv when I was 18 and when
I came back to Victoria Texas my
hometown um I remember like they brought
in these like little girls one night and
I remember my aunt she's like really
pretty tiny little white Spanish lady
and she was talking about how she like
cut like a bunch of money in half and
gave it to like coyotes and then um and
I was like what the [__] like and it was
like it was daing on me I was like oh
damn they like cross these girls over
and then they shorted the [__]
traffickers so he he did like some crazy
[__] and I was like why the [__] is my
aunt with him cuz he's like an
engineering degree and [__] like he
built houses and stuff but then he did
all this like sketchy [__] on the side I
was like what the [__] and then like um
I it dawned on me later on I was like
she's she's only stayed with him through
like some rough [__] cuz he got that big
old dick damn yeah
that's you can't have a big dick and
live a small dick lifestyle hey yeah
yeah you got to earn it [__] over the
cartel and shorting traffickers and in
in my in my mind I like to think it's
heartwarming like he was reuniting like
family that's how I he had something
going for him yeah yeah I think uh
seeing other people's naked body is
sometimes like a positive experience but
sometimes it's like holy [__] I think
you're like I think something's wrong
with you yeah I D you guys know s
contras right
yeah [__] props to that [__] she's
like one of my best friends and like
she's 400 lb and does the naked roast
bottles in like Vegas for skankfest and
I'm like God damn like I want your
confidence like she's so [__] I'm afraid
of showing off 177 pounds yeah I'm I'm
afraid of double that yeah she's double
doubly double dude that [__] is she's
so funny triple man the man that she is
and she's that
man for sure that's um that's some
confidence I I definitely couldn't do
that I I like her blackout set sometimes
she gets like blackout drunk and one
time I saw her perform for four people
at Shakespeare's and she was blackout
drunk she needed help on the stage and
she goes okay so I watch a lot of uh
Nature Documentaries don't do her bits
whales and don't do her
punchline oh she didn't even remember it
should I not do
it she you don't remember the punch line
no I
do press should do the punch line okay
so she goes um so killer whales have
three- foot penises and the trainers
were jacking them off like this and
she's like using her fingers and she
goes okay this is revealing too much of
her bit okay so don't do the B CU like
the full bit but it's like funny yeah
let's not do her bit okay like if she's
still using the bit like which I just
like because it's like not me like doing
the B I just like I'm like crediting her
like that's her bit but it's so funny
what's her name Celia contr she Celia
Celia I won't remember the name but
nice I'm saying it like in in like how I
would say I would sayia if we were
saying it like in a Latin American
accent it be Celia and then like
everyone here calls her Celia but dude
she's like she uh Roseanne was on her
one of her episodes Tony
and it was so emotional I do know who
she is yes I was already friends with
her and like I I told her I was like
[__] I thought you were like somebody's
like [__] sister cuz I saw you
played out in the alley just like
looking down and then yo tonight we
watched someone get like decked so we
were like leaving work cuz I work at a
Calli Club surrounding uh Mothership but
um we watched that dude get decked and
he like hit the ground and the cops had
to come
and it was it was so crazy cuz like the
cops can't like they have to like say
things like where it doesn't look like
it's a big deal and I was like my my
[__] white trash ass was like is he
breathing is he alive someone called the
ambulance called an EMT and the the cops
like you need to walk away and I was
like I work here on six straight and
like they're like I thought it was a
free country American this America it's
crazy because where I grew up um I grew
up like smoking in the mountains but we
would like we would like go up to the
mountains and we'd all smoke in a group
um in a national park and we there's
only one uh gas station uh before you
got there and it's the only place you
got like rolls like rollups and like
like Backwoods or whatever you needed
and we went up there and there's like
one dude and his name was Pudge and we
would go to Pudge and like hey Pudge we
like need we need Backwoods and we want
peach flavor like whatever and he would
give them to us and he would always give
us an extra pack of them he give us an
extra pack and he'd be like hey smoke
one out for Pudge and we'd be like you
got a baby anything you ask so we go to
the mountains and we of course smoke an
extra blunt for him and uh that was like
I don't know like six years ago and my
mom calls me um about a week ago his
name's William government night I'm not
going to give us full government William
but my mom was like uh yeah he just went
to federal prison and I was like why and
he's like he shot and killed somebody on
his property oh
[__] but I never realized how [__]
white trash I am because in my head I
was
like yeah he shot and killed someone on
his property M he was on his property if
he had a do not trespass sign and he
shot him and he shot him that's on them
but my mom was like it's in broad
daylight with no probable cause and I
was
like don't step on my La I thought we
were an
America free my man
Pudge free Pudge you think you can just
step on my lawn hey if I bought a do not
trespass sign from from [__] Lowe's
read that [__] you know it could be like
beware of goldfish get the [__] off of M
I don't give a [__] I'm going to shoot
you with a 95 I swear to God but I
couldn't believe it so uh you guys want
to plug something real
quick um one need to stand up comedy on
Instagram that's really like uh I work
at I work at Sunset Strip Comedy Club go
support the Sunset Strip Brian redband
Club are you the person that cleans the
high ceilings or I sit on my tippy toes
and I clean them all in the bathroom she
has an extension on her whatever red
been asks I'll do it ladder when I first
entered when I first um saw the sunset
STP uh first Ed I
don't I I know I knew about the the tall
ceiling claim and the high ceilings they
are pretty [__]
high well it's a great Club um it was a
great Club I been before the the the the
um the bartenders there um what was his
name the guy that Dylan Dylan I think
that's his name Dylan or Jack Dylan or
Jack one of the guys really nice guy um
anyway the sunset sunset ship that's
probably Dyan Jack's an [__] no I'm
just kidding Jack is an angel and Deon
will that's why I said it because it was
obviously not true he's obviously the
nicest guy ever which is why I could
joke about it um but yeah do you have
anything to plug you want to plug the
Super Bowl check out the Super Bowl
February 11 Super Bowl 58 it's uh um my
Instagram uh who gives a [__] but it's
uh lucky. Willams if you can spell that
[__] L it's um I don't really care if
you follow me or not I'm not trying to
popularize anything but yeah um thank
you for having me on Hans um this has
been I like to popularize the idea of
fascism I think maybe are you trying to
go that could maybe be a good idea if we
give it enough if you give have time
train I can do a mile pretty quick
fascism you want to Fascism the railway
stations I only believe in
cism
fascism cream all right should we end it
I don't give a [__] what you okay it's 3
A.M we got the [__] is 309 yeah YouTube
what the
[__] that was fun